it's time to babble live from the Jon
Lovitz odd gas theatre it's Hollywood
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman pride a
night in Hollywood let you caught
yourself I know who so let's babble the
[ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
oh god bless you I don't look forward
this for a while man I missed the last
one three weeks yes my special guest
host this week will be Kevin Smith which
is a rarity it's nice to have you back
sir this is I didn't I tried not to do
other podcasts like the way your wife
goes out of town sometimes you're like
I'm not gonna jerk off until she comes
home right and I'll jerk off you know
the same thing here I tried not to do
other Hollywood comedy until I came back
here now I'm ready to make fun of our
betters
all right let's do that before we get to
the show I see that term loosely a
little business to take care of want to
give people who are listening heads up
that we're gonna be on the East Coast
and a couple weeks we're gonna be in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania how dare you
boom Philadelphia Pennsylvania get the
[ __ ] out apparently there's still that
East Coast West Coast rapido
Tupac's crowd in the house yeah we're
gonna be in Philly on the 17th of
October that's a Monday night so come on
and see us at the World Cafe live yeah
that's huge for us that's your back yard
right that's my hometown yeah I'm in
Jersey of course your home right around
then cross the river and can be all
[ __ ] cheesesteaks and pretzels for us
oh man
they gained 40 pounds that weekend 40
pounds tonight
thinking about that we good and then
we're in Vegas in November - that's
right we're on the road Babylon [ __ ]
we're moving on we're not the Jeffersons
well not yet but we will be Weezy let's
get right to it with the shoutouts we
like to on occasion say a special word
of thanks to folks who have come
particularly long distances or is
celebrating special occasions I'll give
you a heads up right now is like a
shitload of shoutouts tonight that we
couldn't get to them all so I apologize
in advance if we don't get to yours but
just [ __ ] you
I just can't but if we want show
consolation a wonderful theme song
that's right
James
[Music]
[Applause]
people are cheering getting your [ __ ]
out that's a quick one real quick is
Santiago in the crowd is Santiago where
are you hello sir happy birthday right
you're celebrating a birthday with your
friends as your name really Santiago you
gotta like avenge your father's death or
some of that makeup Montoya it's a
different man name like that it's so
[ __ ] like it's a powerful name an
epic name he can be sit and watching
Babylon with a name like Santiago bills
Jim's John's they watch Babylon Santiago
he's doing his own podcasts about how
he's a avenging his father's death or at
least cliff diving in Acapulco this
comes from Bart justice and Mario those
are his friends Bart justice and Mario
we are the three Crusaders it does sound
a little Saturday morning do you just
hang out with people with better names
than most you're like look when you Rock
Santiago you can't hang out with Ralph
or Kevin you gotta hang out with Marc
justice and Mario barking I don't know
they write that Santiago is celebrating
his birthday tonight what better way
than with booze balloon knots geek news
and Liam Neeson's [ __ ] and I couldn't
agree more
by the way Santiago's single ladies it
says in this email so big bucket of win
and we can find him a nice and liquored
up girl that has no qualms about giving
up the brown eyed Cyclops I get a few
more of these in me some yeah
I've just said it's Friday night in
Hollywood never seen you drink alcohol
before so I don't know what's gonna
happen I did unfortunately we're not
unfortunately tonight I did two shows
back-to-back I did Jay and Bob get old
before this and then this one and
unfortunately I didn't get to go home or
smoke up so I'm doing completely [ __ ]
straight this ever happens I'm like 20
to 20 minutes into the show I'm gonna be
like where am I
once all the THC is gone so in
preparation for that I have a beers a
good idea I also want to ask if but Cory
Smith is in the house Cory Wow bring
Cory guy or girl it's a guy who'd oh
yeah let's raise this sounds like that
doesn't answer my [ __ ] question
coming on a Hollywood babble-on this
Friday for my birthday well happy
birthday Cory congratulations excited to
bring out 11 other people to celebrate
my birthday with me well
fuckin'-a you could come here anytime
Cory yeah yeah keep bringing the numbers
yeah go like that's how we used to do
with my family and I as a kid well every
time we go to Demi's we were like oh
it's his birthday because you get the
free yeah yeah yeah and eventually they
got wise to it they're like he can't
have that many birthdays in one year but
he's starting to look like he has about
a birthday a day cake wise Dave and
patent value oh Jesus Christ
back the [ __ ] off Jesus I'm here with my
friend Pat and my sister Val Dave writes
I'll be the fat drunk guy not drunk
enough hey I'm gonna beat you there
buddy
flying to Los Angeles from Rochester
just to see you guys live well that's
great upstate New York right Dave Road I
hope to be there but being a gentleman
of generous girth I worry about actually
being allowed to fly
they let you on congratulations did you
need to sleep but extender or anything
you did didn't you Dave yeah they let
you on the plane lucky I guess I guess
we know what airline he wasn't flying
yeah really
my friend Pat is an excellent artist
writes Dave what do you do Dave you got
any talents you just hang around
talented people that's what I do and
look where I am what happened your plan
I thought you might enjoy a piece of
work you recently finished a picture of
Harley Quinn I know you and I are both
Harley Quinn fans you know your daughter
after Harley Quinn this is something
that Pat did it's a painting it's pretty
nice mom is the site you can know you
can buy your [ __ ] there one of those
drawings you could jerk off to Ralph
you said it Justin are you adjusting in
the crowd tonight Justin's right there
hello Justin knows his own applaud or
man god bless you I'm with you sir
you're with your brother Nick though
right where's Nick but Nick Nixon quiet
one and that was like [ __ ] dope here
from Dallas Texas I'm breaking on my
brother Nick with me to watch the show
on Friday will be his first HBO
experience that's why he's not clapping
Dallas for this when do they get funny
that's what Nick is asked I was hoping
you could pop his HBO cherry in your
Edwin voice well of course I can don't
you know it's great to have you here
Nick you're quiet but we'll fix that cuz
I'm gonna stick my [ __ ] right in your
ass no go oh my goodness life is for the
living
thanks for coming up from Dallas they
are Fidelis I might take a shot at
YouTube from the grassy knoll
- soon - tsunami indeed yeah John and
Veronica rocky just wings anyway you you
actually uttered something my girlfriend
I are big fans will be at the show to
celebrate our one-year anniversary John
right it's a dating anniversary stop
clapping it's meaningless
it's [ __ ] meaningless now when you're
dating it's easy when you didn't get
[ __ ] marry then no man will clap for
you when you spend a year married every
day every morning the same woman every
night I'm sorry
bad day mr. mr. bitter aside I support
your 12-month bursary John writes I'd
like to ask Kevin for a suggestion for
something sexual we could do to
celebrate the anniversary and the fact
that I just finished moving into her
place before he answers however let me
say that my girlfriend is really cool
and already well let's just say she's
already done with the let's all go
inside so there's no need to talk her
into that right so we need something
else for them to celebrate their
anniversary with something sexual Kevin
for you to come up with since you are
the man with the moves okay first 20
minutes of all nipple work Oh nipple
work then 35 minutes of all labia work
then about 12 minutes to quit work at
that point that's all you'll need and
then and then tell her I don't need to
come this was all about you then when
she falls asleep jerk off to her ass
[Applause]
that's how I won my wife sounds like a
workout video all right you put in 20
minutes of nipple work then about 15
minutes of labia work are you with me
fellas Arnie and Liz beer is it beer
villa be out of course I like seasick
wedding Arnie and Liz are here tonight
celebrating their real anniversary
because they're [ __ ] married right on
every day that's ray same goddamn face
off damn my husband and Arnie I've been
listening the pocket since the beginning
and we love it writes Liz I am really
looking forward to the show because
we're celebrating my birthday and most
importantly our anniversary when Arnie
and I first met I had gone through
cervical cancer treatment and was told
my chances of having kids were slim to
none but Arnie married me anyway and our
life is amazing this is the first date
we've had in a long time and probably
the last for a while because we have a
beautiful 11 month old little girl at
home and I'm five months pregnant oh my
god
Arnie Arnie yeah leave the [ __ ] alone
no I'll show those doctors wrong we're
gonna beat the odds and I'm gonna beat
my dick this says not only does this
[ __ ] give me amazing orgasms but
beautiful babies I wish someone would
say that about my [ __ ] dick never
could you please tell my adore him and
wish us a happy anniversary in your
David Bowie voice thanks for making me
laugh at 1:00 a.m. while I'm up with a
teething fussy baby Liz PS I like Jersey
girl no you don't yeah she does do the
Bowie I like the alright James your
sperm is really something your [ __ ]
really gets the job done
yo Chisolm beat the odds you knocked her
up with your load all right here we go
congratulations I'm disenfranchised fern
was like that super human sperm way to
be fertile man that's right all right we
get emails from around the world and
from time to time we like to read them
out James
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions what's up
guys my name is indi and I've been a
loyal listener since the beginning I
live in Madrid Spain and not a lot of
people listen to HBO here so I decided
to make a teaser trailer to a fake movie
based on Ralph's impressions just to
help spread the word it's a movie called
the garmi here's the teeler teaser
trailer I hope you enjoy it and never
stop babbling and since I'm writing you
could I get a shout out for my
girlfriend you can surprise me with the
voice but I'll just give you two key
words Elise and ass
thanks indie at least your boyfriend's
an ass he left it up to me that was a
mistake true here is that this is pretty
amazing a guy who lives in Madrid put
together this teaser trailer for a movie
that doesn't exist using pieces of audio
from our show I was very impressed
here's a little teaser trailer for a
movie he made up called the garmi
oh great Horrors in that town but let me
use the [ __ ] God Finnegan and bleeding
to death but he's not [ __ ] nearly I
offer a silent apology to the victims I
failed to protect I don't I'm too
worried about my [ __ ] because
oh let's cool
[Music]
[Applause]
there's so much more talented than we
better show they're making then we're
doing god bless them this email comes
from Kimball in Colorado the reason I'm
writing is because I just watched red
state which I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of
those you who haven't seen red state by
the way you really owe it to yourself
I'm not just saying that great flick
just got thinking about how much Ralph's
character Caleb reminded me of classic
mute serial killers like Jason Voorhees
and Michael Myers this led me to think
that a red state sequel should be made
featuring Caleb returning from the grave
as a zombie a machete-wielding monster
who haunts Cooper's Dell and kills
teenagers who dare to come there and
indulge in their naughty business this
of course would lead to an entire series
of red state movies which would climax
in the epic film red state six-six-six
Caleb versus Jay and Silent Bob I've
taken upon myself to make a poster for
red state - I hope you enjoy this is
from Kimball and Colorado this was the
most it would look like for a red state
- Caleb as a zombie holding a machete
and I'm glad Kimble cares about my movie
career because this one is retiring it
as just ruined it was asking for a
sequel to red state when we're in
production he's like money what do you
mean I get killed can I come back I'm
like no come on can't God come down and
raise me from the bed actually in that
movie words exactly James Clark writes
longtime fan big fan of Kevin's films
even cop-out while sober he writes when
that's impressive
thanks for the Asterix dude
my cousin Shawn have been raving about
the podcast forever so I finally decided
to check it out within a week I've
listened to all 52 podcasts and
absolutely loved it that's pretty
impressive the one thing I don't like
about the show however is how ralph
talks about Sarah Jessica Parker James
writes to those who have criticized the
looks of Sarah Jessica Parker I say nay
it would behoove you to have some common
courtesy and stop making such unbridled
remarks it's unfair to saddle her with
this burden of ugliness someone needs to
take the reins here and say whoa this is
going too far
why do we need to trot out these same
cracks every time her name comes up the
next time she makes a movie I'll
definitely pony up the cash to see it
Babylon James Clark well thank you James
and while we're talking about talented
listeners Dan leather Dale writes from
London England
he has he has come up with an entire new
concept and a new segment for the for
the podcast that he has sent me in
complete form it's got an introduction
it's God know a videotape it's got
everything so we got writers now we have
writers thank God thought of a new
segment you guys could do for the HBO
podcast have you ever seen an acting
performance from an a-list actor that
you thought was a little subpar compared
to their better work I think that you
guys with the help from the listenership
would share these performances to the
world and a weekly segment called
exquisite acting I think I've attached
an intro you could use in a clip of
Pierce Brosnan getting quite angry from
a film from 1988 called Taff and Dan
leather Dale so here is the intro for a
new segment called exquisite acting
[Music]
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with Ralph Garman
I bet he's doing all the work for Dino
British accent some pretty cool
pre-classic this is the video he sent in
this is Pierce Brosnan of course James
Bond he's had a big body at work maybe
this is not his finest moment this is
just a quick scene from a movie he made
1988 called kafon and he may have been a
little over the top in this particular
scene on this particular line where was
the director at a coffee break
I don't know that director deserves a
pat on the back man how do you get
something that big out of sudden maybe
you shouldn't be living here yeah look
at that one more time James for
Whitesnake video one more time' i was
very impressed by by his performance in
this hungover that day this week we've
got another one of our hollywood helpers
someone in show business who has stepped
up and gotten outside of their own ego
and done something for somebody else
here's the only problem with this
segment Kevin Smith you may know him
doesn't like be the intro for this piece
the theme song yeah but let's play the
old Hollywood helpers theme song James
[Music]
mr. thanks mister I thought it was sweet
it was nice you thought it wasn't hard
enough there have enough edge deleted
edge and a couple episodes ago Kevin
fell in love with a segment of musical
segments someone sent in it was Pacino
asking for more margaritas it was a
little soon jingle
he said that should be the helpers [ __ ]
does Pacino uttering margaritas have to
do with Hollywood helping and then he
dropped a little little wine he said
well maybe someone can edit this in well
you've got to be careful what you ask
for because Harry Cohn who did the
original remixed it and here's our new
Hollywood helpers theme James this
week's Hollywood helpers Sean Penn
believe it or not Sean Penn it turns out
get some credit for getting those two
hikers freed from Iran I thought you're
gonna say he [ __ ] knocked out a dude
with a pot of coffee
Josh Patel and Jane Bauer those are the
guys the two hikers that were held by
Iran for I don't know two years they
were oh my god yes yeah so Sean Penn
stepped up and he called up his friend
venezuelan President Hugo Chavez you
laugh but they're actually pals they
hang out why and Hugo Chavez is pals
with Mahmoud Ahmadinejad the iranian
President Mahmoud Ahmadinejad they see
the Jew that comes over here every once
in a while is like we don't have a key
yes no dancing around no everybody very
straight yeah when we have a gay but six
we look at [ __ ] porn
so Shawn's representative told The
Hollywood Reporter yes it's true he was
involved and second is there such a
thing as [ __ ] Porter's there are the
distinction classifications like his
[ __ ] pouring his [ __ ] porn his ass porn
his City pouring I sure I've never heard
that yeah
[ __ ] straight porn is known as [ __ ]
porn really yeah
Shawn's representative says he was
involved in working towards their
release however he is not providing
details or offering a statement but
Shawn apparently was making phone calls
on behalf of these two hikers and got
him released so that's pretty impressive
awesome totally awesome
way to go I got them released on our
time how about some [ __ ] that should not
be missed last week's kiss was great
last week's was an episode of The
Flintstones where Barney Rubble was
making a joke about his own [ __ ] mark
told the cartoon really yeah wildly
inappropriate joke that was written into
the Flintstones I guess they hoped no
one would catch but we caught it last
night
don't explain this segment for those
who've never seen it or heard it [ __ ]
that should not be is where we take a
look mostly at movies and we find
glaring moments that have just gone
horribly horribly wrong in these movies
I mean there's dozens sometimes hundreds
of people watch these films before they
reach you in the theaters or on
television and you would think somebody
would catch these glaring errors and no
one does and these movies reach the
screens or reach your television set and
it's just unbelievable the stuff that
slips through the cracks we've taken a
look at a ton of stuff my favorite is
Wildcats where there's a black running
back gets handed the ball he gets
attacked when he when he stands up he's
Woody Harrelson it's it's that kind of
[ __ ] I'm talking about
in anaconda though the waterfalls going
backwards no one bothered to straighten
that out this week's movie is bad boys
not the one with Will Smith and the og
one with Sean Sean Penn right speaking
of Sean Penn
he plays a kid in Chicago named Mick
O'Brien Jewish kid who's sent to reform
school
after killing Paco Marino's kid brother
unfortunately he runs into Paco Moreno
in the reform school where he is bent
into the prison and that's played by
East Side Morales Sean pan and Esai
Morales in this scene are fighting and
everyone is cheering them on and there's
it's a brutal fight going on inside the
reformatory but there is something going
on to the left if you watch the left
side of your screen will show it a
couple times so you'll catch it it's
un-fuckin'-believable that this movie
got on two screens without someone
saying we got to take that out here is
bad boys from 1983 this side I got my
race reporter so I'll show you when we
get into it here's the fight that fight
Esai Morales and then look what's going
on here one more time just insane well
who's in there for Mario it's a [ __ ]
camera crew this is a grip over here in
a cameraman shooting the lights on the
floor it's in the [ __ ] movie
doesn't somebody saying hey we got giant
panaflex [ __ ] camera on the floor
they're shooting a 72 millimeter in the
IMAX can we just can we cut that scene
no no one will know it is that there's
too much going on this days is that
guy's got a shiv this other guy has like
a food tray guys got a movie camera it
happens all the time
makes me angry and angry every time I do
this segment they take us for suckers
there's a wait a second that was in 1983
yes it's 2011 that's almost 30 years ago
yeah you're still mad yes still mad
about it all right let's get right into
the big stories of the week when it
comes to showbiz news Ashton Kutcher
you're in trouble what happened oh you
haven't heard no he loved the Hollywood
babble-on I catch up on all the news
you're in the business man you should be
plugged in I'm not in their business
Ashton Kutcher of course looks like he's
on top of the world it's got a hot
sitcom now biggest ratings ever for the
premiere episode of two and a half yes
married to a beautiful older woman named
Demi Moore demigod yes yes and
you think he has the world by the ass
well that's just goes to show you
success and money isn't everything my
prince because he's in big trouble at
home it turns out that he's been busted
[ __ ] somebody else he cheated on me
more he did and apparently this isn't
the first time and now word is that
they're separated so she's single
you think she's gonna go from - new
culture to you is that what your thought
I read not for me
alright unless she was into threesomes
alright
rumor has it that this has happened
before and this is the last straw this
is why you think she's the person I'm
guessing she is yes right I thought
scripted yeah even going back like she
wasn't blaming on Rio when she was young
yeah yeah and she was happy but still
she's always seemed kind of wild to me
like when he got married to her some
people were like she's older than him
but I'm like you know the [ __ ] she's
forgotten more about how to make a dude
come than he'll ever know
yeah about making a dude come yeah she
makes a dude comment about it that
Ashton yeah forgot about making another
dude yeah what resumed Lee he makes
himself okay but she knows more like
she's just wisdom she's like the Yoda of
[ __ ] I assume yeah they're separated
not just because of their marital
situation but they're on opposite coasts
because she's working on a movie and
he's here in Los Angeles doing his
sitcom so they did not spend their
anniversary together their sixth
anniversary apparently the night of
their anniversary
he was caught [ __ ] a 23 year old down
in San Diego at the Hard Rock Hotel in
San Diego 23 and here's my theory and
I've always said this it doesn't work
when an older woman marries a young dude
it's women always say to me no it's the
same thing when an older man marries a
young girl no it's not because guys are
pigs and if they get the chance to get
some young [ __ ] they're going to take
that chance so right yeah and apparently
he did now the girl her name is Sarah
Leal he picked the wrong girl because
she is willing to sell her story this
week she's announced for 250,000 dollars
to any tabloid that'll pay her in her
defense she said if Ashton pays me
twenty fifty thousand dollars I won't
tell anybody the story
she's a sweetheart can that be counted
as black now not if you do it publicly I
guess here's a photo of Sara Lee ladies
who just released today everyone was
wondering what she looked like this is
her this is the little blonde number he
was with and this is the photo that
apparently busted Ashton this is them
leaving the hotel him driving her in the
backseat this is the photo that gotten
him into trouble
so apparently trouble in paradise with
about that show dude you get that role
on that show and you just cook you think
I'm a mess
cratering your life in the regardless or
II think Jon Cryer just hanging his head
saying oh [ __ ] not it yeah I think right
about now Jon Cryer is [ __ ] chief
Brody and jaws too you know he's just
like I've seen a shark and you better do
something about this one cuz I'm going
through that hell again that's perfect
they better shut down the beaches Ralph
a couple episodes ago I showed you guys
a photograph I can't remember if you
were here for this one or not do you
remember the photograph of Nicolas Cage
that was being sold on eBay no it was a
photo that was presumably Nicolas Cage
from a hundred years ago and the person
who was selling it saying this has
proved that Nicolas Cage is a vampire
and has lived forever and it was a it
was a type of graph at in tip agraphia
guy who looked exactly like Nicolas Cage
from the Civil War and everyone was
saying it's it's uncanny this is proof
positive that he is otherworldly and
he's been around for hundreds of years
and everyone had a big joke about it it
was a photo from 1870 from Tennessee it
was a civil war photo of a guy looked
exactly like Nicolas Cage and we all
laughed well this week on eBay was
posted a photo from 1860 of a young John
Travolta
and the seller of this photo who is
asking by the way $250,000 that is the
number of the day
Sarah Leal wants that and this guy wants
it for the photograph this says this guy
says and I'm reading from the posting on
eBay this is a picture of John Travolta
from 1860 it is clear as day as the day
was taken roughly 151 years ago I know
you're all saying John Travolta is alive
today in 2011 and he doesn't look 151
years old well for those who don't know
John Travolta is a Scientologist and
many Scientologists can time travel now
I want to join ya see it's worth
whatever you pay over take a Nev meter
test now the belief is the time travel
is possible among Scientologists and
many of them has happened before and
they've traveled into the past so here's
a photo of John Travolta when he was
time traveling back to 1860 there is him
there's young Travolta to the left and
there's young Travolta in from 1860
that's a pretty close look so for
250,000 dollars you can have proof that
Tom Travolta Don John Travolta is a time
traveler we have proof right here for
free that's true we do another day
another actor celebrity thrown off of an
airline this time it was the star of the
l word named Alicia Haley she was thrown
off an airline because she was making
out with her lesbian girlfriend what our
line with that what would be so
intolerant as to throw off people who
are just having a good time
Southwest Airlines it turns out Kevin so
apparently the reason they asked her to
get off the place because Southwest is a
family airline cab right and they don't
cotton to that court of behavior in
their seats to girls McAnally chicks
pissing Jase bad why like and that's the
one kind of kissing you do want to see
on a plane that's what I'm thinking
pretty hot just like all of a sudden you
look up and two chicks are making out
I'd be like buy more tickets
let's always fly this airline leashes
now demanding a public apology from
Southwest calling for her fans and gay
people everywhere to boycott Southwest
Airlines for its homophobic policies and
she wrote and tweeted they don't like us
so Kevin you've got people in your
corner they don't like gay people fat
people they don't like dudes with their
pants hanging down that's right Billy
Joe Armstrong from Green Day was booted
off that plate as well this is this
literally is the principal of Airlines
you know it's just like they're always
going like pull up your pants stop
kissing lose weight a lot of Hoops to
jump through just to get on an airplane
with you and when you get on the plane
you'd imagine like wow once we get on
it's gonna be paradise in the air no
it's not you know they make you jump
through hoops and like now [ __ ] to sit
in your shitty little seat no it's a bus
it's a repair bus and now they make you
jump through hoops I know everybody here
watches Dancing with the Stars I'll ask
the people applauding why but just a
real quick recap
elisabetta canalis ex-girlfriend of
George Clooney was booted off this week
which makes me angry I don't watch my
don't like when hot girls are sad I know
that much and she must have been sad but
she was booted off but the real story of
the week was that Nancy Grace you know
her from HLN she's got the show she was
the the big talk of the town when the
Casey Anthony trial was going she was so
outraged she was furious when they when
the verdict came back she said the devil
was dancing tonight when that verdict
came back and that Casey Anthony got off
so lightly she was dancing and Dancing
with the Stars when her nipple popped
out yeah that chicks nipple was out on
TV yeah there's like four hot chicks on
the show and Nancy Grace's [ __ ] nipple
pops out just goes to show you God is
not a fan of Dancing with the Stars I
brought in a photo okay
Azaria have you eat have you eaten here
at the Lovitz I'm sorry in the name of
journalism I have to I have to produce
the evidence let me get my laser pointer
again I believe we've got the photo here
if you look right there yeah right there
Donna that's more areola than nipple
yeah that's that's that's areola Perales
right there she she was talking to the
judges with her tit hanging out
basically is what happened and they gave
her a high enough grades that she's
another week so I guess she knows what
she's doing cuz she got a [ __ ] quato
Papa number two I know is the devil is
dancing tonight well I'm saying more
annoying TV personalities in the news
Andy Rooney of 60 minutes fame will be
doing his last broadcast this Sunday
night on 60 minutes last regular
appearance Rooney who is 92 has been
featured on 60 minutes since 1978 holy
[ __ ] he is retiring this weekend after
his 1090 seventh appearance on 60
minutes the chairman of CBS News said he
will always have an open door and have
an ability to speak his mind on 60
minutes whenever the urge hits him
that's a bad idea Jeff Fager of CBS News
he's 92 cuz the next thing you know he's
gonna come in and say why is my tapioca
pudding warm he's gonna have complaints
that's 92 year old Sam we don't want to
hear that complaints like one day I'm
gonna die soon I can't see past my
eyebrows any longer well well that said
that makes me feel old well I've been
watching that dude I mean I'll watch 60
minutes all the time but he's been on 60
minutes since I was a kid 78 I was eight
years old yeah so to hear that that
debate saw your whole life yeah yeah
pretty much
yeah and that just means that like he's
getting ready to wind up which means in
about a few years there won't be an Andy
Rooney on 60 minutes so everyone should
tune in and watch that last one he is
kind of a television institution at this
point big buck gonna win that guy's that
as a good reader I know he's not dead
but he won't be we'll see him because
he's still alive to see him in
Tinseltown's dish
oh yeah maybe next week my reason to
live when I left television I'm just
going to lay down and die now like we
can tear that one Andy most annoying
celebrities while we're talking about
Andy Rooney interesting poll this week
from Parade magazine this is the top
five most annoying celebrities as polled
by you the American public this is one
of those moments I thank God we're not
celebrities me too because we'd make
we'd be on their number five on the most
annoying celebrity list from parade
magazines poll Donald Trump they only
got five percent of the vote I thought
it'd be bigger these are people really
irritated bomber are they're just kind
of been different I think they're
irritated by him really I mean that's it
he's got a big show that Celebrity
Apprentice gets pretty good numbers and
people watch I think they are cheesed
off in him okay because he's so he's so
pompous and everything he does is the
greatest in the best it the biggest
hotel ever in the history of New York
City in hotels that have ever had
windows we have the most [ __ ] you so
bombastic Lindsay Lohan 16% of the vote
came in number for Snooki of the Jersey
Shore got 21% of the vote Charlie Sheen
27% of the vote came in at number two
and the number one top vote-getter for
the most annoying celebrity in America
anyone would take a guess
the Chelsea Handler I wish I'd be
vindicated Kim Kardashian absolutely
know number one that's where we are in
this country that she counts as a
celebrity I know
I'd still [ __ ] her though they didn't
they didn't have that question on the
poll maybe that's what's annoying I
wouldn't [ __ ] any of these other people
but I said for that one yeah that one
while we're talking about [ __ ]
celebrities Rihanna in the news this
week I saw a picture of her with her top
off yes I saw her boobies boobies
boobies she was in Northern Ireland
shooting a video on a farm that was
owned by a Northern Ireland gentleman
named Northern Ireland gentleman he's
Irish that's what I'm trying to get it
named Allen Graham and he was watching
them film the video and he said he had
no idea who Rihanna was and she was
filming the video she started with a
flannel shirt and then she stripped down
to a Stars and Stripes bikini and then a
red bra and then she went topless and
that is when he drew the line he hopped
off of his tractor and stopped the shoot
really ran into the shoot and said no no
please no no no no no that's what he
said he said not on my land he stopped
the whole shoot said you can know where
he can shoot here because that Barbados
chick is showing her boobs
he's like I'm seeing her pink stars
yellow moons orange clovers here's the
neck here's a shot of Rihanna running
through the field with her boobies going
in the breeze it's more of her arms yeah
it were ours we saw more of Nancy Grace
than we did a Rihanna for joy but yeah
he said no and is the first time I've
ever been ashamed to be Irish quite
frankly because he should have said
let's go
let's do it on my tractor actor actor
Betty White
she should die soon right oh you're with
me in a nest full of Betty White
yeah you've had an [ __ ] ever right
look I get it I know her careers had a
resurgence and she's a national treasure
whatever but [ __ ] enough with the
Betty White Betty White if you know you
would oh yeah let me into that funny you
know the kind of [ __ ] she would know to
bring to the table and whatnot you
dismiss her Betty Betty White would [ __ ]
you out of this world [ __ ] you and
Betty White across from each other in
tables like that scene in Raiders of the
Lost Ark and she's Karen Allen as Marion
Ravenwood you the big [ __ ] Apollo
guys it's like oh because Betty White's
like [ __ ] you know how much [ __ ]
I've done get over here give it again
Garmin she just hold your head like this
why should reruns of the Golden Girls
well what happens when I enter her and
snap her pelvis when osteoporosis rears
its ugly head and her bones turned to
dust with my powerful man thrust problem
she's got to worry about his year
low-hanging balls exactly slip in
between our legs and crashing her in the
back of the head
[Music]
but cussing that poor woman I would
break her in half
I would [ __ ] her to dust is what would
happen you're like the [ __ ] lost art
it's right Italy she'd be like a mummy
she was like a Betty White shaped cloud
after I have her I was inside of her
looks like she ran in the car - she's
[ __ ] 90 enough already with Betty
White is awesome she brings the funny
man funny will turn me on even for a
woman at that age it's like she's clever
well you may change your mind this week
because she's just released her first
rap song yeah seeing that you're on my
side she's got a new rap song that she
did with a British singer-songwriter
named Luciana
and apparently Luciana had a hit with a
song called I'm still hot and so she and
Betty White have done a remix where it's
a duet where Betty White talks about how
she's still hot okay
and I think I don't know if hot flashes
count but via lyrics something like I
may be senior but so what I'm still hot
I left my Emmys in my beatbox that what
she calls her badge that where she puts
it right on the bacon that trophy is
awfully cruel looking I will get you
sweaty because I'm big Betty she writes
I brought it a little taste of the audio
of Betty White singing her new rap song
okay and after you hear this I'm sure
like I you will be looking forward to
next week's Tinseltown sniffs in the
hope will be joining Andy Rooney in our
bigs here's a little piece of Betty
White
[Music]
no you're not Betty oh I'm sorry you get
the booby prize they're not here to
cause no trouble she's just here to do
the Super Bowl most simplistic wrap you
could give a ninety-year-old yeah well
and that is right and I'm doing wrapping
it ain't crap pretty damn simple they
wrote it phonetically for her I think to
get through it good for her though she
deserves it man
Arnold Schwarzenegger in the news our
former governor here in California has
commissioned seven larger-than-life
bronze statues of himself appreciate the
fans appreciation Ferb says he likes him
somehow that's for sure glad to see that
hold knocking up your maid and losing
your wife hasn't ruined his ego in any
way the statues are eight feet tall five
hundred and eighty pounds of bronze he
has made seven of them no word on what
he's gonna do with all of them but he
said definitely he's gonna keep one for
himself he sounds something he can [ __ ]
besides the made us look old the bronze
I love you you're so hard and your pecs
are so perfect he's sending one to Thal
Austria that's his birthplace of course
where they had the Arnold Schwarzenegger
Museum right in other words going to
Columbus Ohio where they have the Arnold
Fitness weekend every year they have a
big bodybuilding competition did someone
just cheer the Arnold Fitness weekend
yeah it's great
I sell as steroids at the back of a van
in the parking lot me to be by my statue
he was visiting the company where they
were making them and they asked him what
he thought he said this is fantastic
this is fantastic he kept saying over
and over again when he came
[Laughter]
and they mix that into the bronze so
when you buy one of these statues is a
little piece of Arnold it comes home
with you he didn't know exactly how many
should make sure the sculptor
recommended that he get one for every
mr. Olympia title he ever made and that
was seven mr. Olympia titles Arnold said
perfect what do you weigh okay pounds
are you know one for every pound how
many days of the week are there so no
word on what the other three are going
but one's going to him the other two are
going away and then I'm sure sure his
wife will keep one just for target
practice do you think he can request
like could do me as The Terminator
apparently they did the style he took
was when he won the mr. Olympia contest
that's the that's the body type all
seven of the statue gonna be that yeah
him and his like most about man like
here's me as corner
don't I look badass here's me as junior
with a big pregnant belly all the way
that just kept Smith it's like a safe
it's got a combination on you can keep
your valuables inside of it here's me a
twins a little statue comes of that in
DeVito like bookends looks like there's
some damage on that statue Arnold is
that a tumor it's not a tumor I might
statue if you want to live get your ass
to my statues
this story broke my heart and I know
your friend of a prince yeah yeah you've
worked with the man yeah more or less
yeah but I like em I dig the music maybe
not the guy so much but he's a Galvin
Artie but this story disappointed me you
remember the time don't you the time or
stay in the time they were on the sound
track yeah I those you who don't
remember the time what a great R&B band
of the 80s here's a little taste of
probably their biggest hit and this was
the one featured in your movies jungle
love
[Music]
most literally trying to remember the
dance we shot that ten years ago I was
like what was it then it was like oh
it's just this it was suede Jesse
neuroma the best part of the [ __ ]
time act is look the music is pretty
damn amazing yeah
they had this little relationship this
this kind of chemistry more stay the
lead singer and Jerome who are
essentially his manservant Jeff so he
would be like in the middle of singing
and he'd be like Jerome get me a mirror
and Jerome would come out and hold the
mirror for Morris while he fixed his
hair and then went back to sing out and
I remember being like a lame white kid
in the suburbs 1983 I was like that's
the coolest thing I've ever seen I want
me a black manservant and then people
said you don't do that those days ago
yeah yeah but then I found Jason news
there you go so I found me a white man
serving we got to bring us a beer on
stage for you sometime during a Babylon
so you can get fresh and then come back
I dream all the time of bringing
somebody out on stage like someone give
me a mirror well then he would witness
comon to the audience yes and I with the
jheri curl we just stick to somebody's
face when the crowd
leave the show that was awesome I love
in time someone helped me with this I
stuck well the original members of the
time Morris de Jimmy Jam Terry Lewis
Jesse Johnson Jerome Benton they've
gotten they got back together they're
releasing a new CD yes on October the
18th called condensate and the bad news
is Prince put those guys together in
1981 yes and now he refuses to let them
use the name the time he didn't say he
just said no he's got rights to the name
he owns the name and they said we'd like
to go back on the road and release a new
CD and he said no dick move dick move
right like why what are you what are you
gonna gain by holding that name but he's
not gonna throw together a bunch of new
seven guys and make them at the time he
doesn't need the money so why won't he
just let them be the time maybe just mad
at them well you know he didn't like me
because the [ __ ] I said about him on
evening with Kevin Smith and then we put
worse day and the time in Jay and Silent
Bob strike back so maybe he's done
holding a 10-year [ __ ] grudge yeah
and he's like here's how you this is how
I [ __ ] you over for being in that movie
you can't have the name that's one
theory they're now calling themselves
the original seven that's the man's the
name yeah with make owns owns the
artists formerly known as the time that
would've been like the biggest [ __ ] you
ever to that little glimpse [ __ ]
I like it I like it that's smart ya know
but they're the original seven so if
you're looking for their music on their
new CD you have to go to original seven
and it's spelled the number seven
numerical seven ven so they make it
[ __ ] impossible to buy their CD is
what I'm Anne Thompson I'm telling you
try to type that into amazon.com Jimmy
Jam and Terry Lewis also like produced a
bunch of Jennifer the very famous
talented cut excuse me talentless [ __ ]
news
Brad Pitt this week refused to talk to
Chelsea Handler go on her talk show to
talk about money why some people have
taste when it comes to going on the
Chelsea Handler show wait let's see why
he didn't go on her show well maybe it's
because she called his wife a [ __ ] when
she was doing stand-up comedy here's
what Angelina Jolie yeah oh so he was
like I'm not going on her show yeah
apparently he reached out to Brad Pitt
who was doing interviews with everybody
to promote Moneyball he's really sort of
desperate to make this movie a hit he
did NPR I do the Today Show he did a
sit-down with Anderson Cooper I mean
he's been he's been talking about
Jennifer Aniston - yeah he never did
that before
and he's also claiming to be still good
friends with Jennifer so Chelsea
Handler's people have said but I'm good
friends with Jennifer and since you're
good friends with Jennifer you guys have
an amicable split why don't you come in
and sit down and we'll promote your
movie on the talk show
he said no I'm gonna pass probably cuz
he she called Anjali Julia could
somebody say that the media like we
think it's because of this well someone
from the show who refused to be named
said Chelsea would have loved to have
Brad on the show she's had some of the
biggest stars in the world or a show to
promote their films if he's still good
friends with Jen then he would have done
e but he's full of it and Chelsea knows
it that's why he wouldn't talk with her
he doesn't have the balls oh so she said
like if you're so good fry if you're
such good friends with Jennifer and my
mom is show because Jennifer and I are
good friends
are they good friends yeah they think
they vacation together and they could do
kunti things together they're going on
conventions together they're such good
friends that conceivably
Jennifer Aston was like that sounds like
a thing that like girlfriends collude
together and be like that
yeah make him see nice things yes he
likes me yeah
check the box do you like me check this
box do you not check that box
chelsey hat breath breath put on her
show and she did one of those things the
paper okay pick a color why we're
talking about Brad Pitt if you've seen
Moneyball you may see Moneyball good
movie Moneyball I have not seen Scott
Mosier saw and he said he loved it it's
really good I'm not a baseball fan per
se but you don't have to be to enjoyed
this so much really well
highest-grossing baseball film and
adjusted dollars of all fun really more
than the natural yes love that movie the
natural yeah more than that funny make
the highest-grossing baseball film up
until Moneyball was the Benchwarmers
shut the [ __ ] up and adjusted grosses
yes more than Field of Dreams way more
field dreams incredibly inch warmers
an opening John [ __ ] Lovitz was in
the Benchwarmers up until recently he
had the highest rated baseball comedy
Voltron baseball movie of all time you
saw him you liked it though yeah he was
real good in it but everyone notices
throughout the whole film he's
constantly stuffing his face he's eating
Brad Brad Pitt does not in the Ocean's
eleven movie - well here's the thing New
York Magazine you haven't got that
vulture calm that website where they do
all the entertainment news I love a
notice it - and they put together a list
and they said Brad Pitt eats everything
all the time in all of his movies let's
just go - it's his comfort as an actor
he likes to work with a prop I guess and
food seems to be his go-to it's ironic
because if you watch Ocean's eleven it's
a pretty crap food but he's a pretty
thin guy yeah and in that movie in
almost every scene he has something in
his hand that he's about to eat or is
eating in almost every movie he's eating
something that says they went through
all of his films and they came up with
54 different food items that he has
eaten over his career
they've got the entire listen the way
because eating that much he would look
more like me than Brad that's what I'm
saying some of the things he's eaten
throughout his career baked beans and
Johnny suede well that's what we all
remember from Johnny suede right yeah
accordin beaten cabbage in the devil's
own cotton candy in Ocean's eleven
amongst other things dumplings in
Ocean's thirteen human blood an
interview with a vampire
another really counts that doesn't care
yeah prison gruel you know I really
doesn't count cuz II didn't want to do
it he was an unwilling bamboo that's
right yeah but a fascinating list you
should check it out the NY mag comm is
where they had that is his move he likes
to eat in movies if you watch he's
always that's his go-to a lot of actors
like that's something to do so they
don't they're self-conscious with their
hands now that's his great news this
week Johnny Depp will be Tonto and The
Lone Ranger so they're gonna go forward
with the movie Disney has greenlit that
film it's gonna happen they drop the
budget a little bit how much did they
shave off the budget to make it happen
well they scalped it basically is what
they did oh shut up
now all the sudden they have taste
[Music]
Disney said we're not gonna make a Lone
Ranger movie for 250 million dollars
that's outrageous ridiculous it's a
Western you should be able to make a
Western for a lot less than that the
westerns in this business traditionally
it was always the cheapest movie to
produce it's why there were so many bad
they've made him because it was easy
they just need dust and horses and they
had the backlot sports that they would
churn out westerns because they were
very inexpensive to produce them when we
did this story originally the outrage of
everybody was like 250 million for a
[ __ ] cowboy movie like this is
impossible
and so they cancelled it and said look
maybe it'll happen if we can bring that
budget down to something responsible
race have they slashed the budget from
250 million dollars to 215 million
dollars
the Disney said well those kind of
numbers we can't resist unbelievable 35
that was the only difference there yeah
that was it I think that movies an ATM
that's looks like printing money John
Johnny Depp in a [ __ ] iconic role
that even though it's like the Lone
Ranger and Tonto aren't like insanely
popular to this generation but they're
well well [ __ ] known and stuff and he
always captures people's imagination
brings different spin to it so at the
end of the day even though it's like 215
for a [ __ ] cowboy movie I bet you
they'll make a [ __ ] ton of money but
there is some risk in this version
because it's due it's not your you know
the traditional loan ring what are they
doing in this version Tonto owns a
casino I'm kidding I knew was a joke
yeah I was gonna flip the table I was so
outraged mmm you play blackjack must get
22 more can you get out of my casino how
tell Smith his booze instead of smoke
because he's like attacking the audience
yeah come on bring it
welcome white um to the show more
casting news Taylor louder on the heels
of his huge success in abduction why did
not do well oh dude no no make eleven
million dollars in its opening weekend
so people are rejecting Taylor Lautner's
or an action star but still I saw that
the demographics on it we're [ __ ] very
impressive like they were like we made
11 million but you know came out for it
chicks really yeah they say there's hope
for him like they feel like they'll give
them another run at it because like
ladies came out to see that guy we're
going to find you not if I find you
first
did the trailers were a little kind of
like in a world where [ __ ] to
horrible [ __ ] alright boy you guys are
in big trouble now cuz here I come
I got a motorcycle under God and you
guys are gonna be sorry this little man
is at the end of his rope you guys
pushed me too far I'm serious I'm
totally cheesed off it's the adventure
of a lifetime in which he meets a
beautiful woman come on I'll keep you
safe just get into my Hello Kitty
backpack you told in touch magazine he
is desperate to be the lead in the
remake of Dirty Dancing so he wants to
play Jennifer grace I believe you know
what the Patrick Swayze role he says
he's been taking dance lessons now for
months preparing for the audition this
is the role of a lifetime for you know
he's been in the mirror for a [ __ ]
long time just going like nobody puts
Baby in a corner
nobody puts Baby nobody puts Baby in a
corner
my girlfriend got pregnant so he has a
dagger on the morsing Twitter your dad's
a doctor maybe he could help us I don't
know anything there's only me and some
girls laughing cuz
remember that I'm at a time of my life
that step three you feel it in here
gotta feel it in here and while we're
talking about casting news looks like
I've got to do a new Bond girl
for James Bond 23 as they're calling we
don't have a title yet because they
can't think of anything more [ __ ] up
in Quantum of Solace James Bond 183 the
23 a new actress has been and this has
been speculated on for a month now P
were saying who's the new Bond girl
gonna be names been thrown around Frieda
Pinto
from no no no and she was in plan of the
ex - yeah
Olivia Wilde I'm just gonna bring a
memento I'm gonna write it in in sharpie
but here bro you know every time I bring
up her name what she looks I just need
to carry a picture of her in my wallet
so every time you
I could be like Oh heard a lot of nays
been thrown around but looks like we
have our new Bond girl this week it was
it's well it's not officially announced
it looks like French actress
Berenice Marlowe is going to be the new
Bond girl her name's Bernice
Berenice yeah Bernice goddamn friend
she's Berenice yeah but in America it's
Bernice it's like meet the sexy new Bond
girl Bernice also sorry Edna Bertha and
Gladys with a special appearance by peg
people are saying she doesn't have a lot
of experience she's only been on French
television she's never made a major
motion picture before it's they're
saying why would they cast her as a Bond
girl yeah and I say well this is the
picture they released of her this week
there you go that's all you need to know
no it's a beautiful French woman
all right uh she could be the Bond girl
joining a very prestigious list of
people like Charlie Sheen's ex-wife
Denise Richard she was about he was a
bun she was a nuclear scientist in their
movie dr. Christmas Jones I was right
her name was Christmas yeah and I
actually had the unfortunate
circumstance of interviewing her on the
red carpet of that film why because
there was a time with the radio station
they were doing the premiere and we they
bought a big commercial buy on the
station and one of the deals was we had
to go down and host the red carpet so I
went down there and you have to stand on
a little box and you interview all the
celebrities when they come by and they
don't want to talk to you and you don't
want to talk to them but it's it's you
know blicket or because of people
standing around the red carpet they want
to hear something from the celebrities
right so everybody to come by and Pierce
probably could not have been more
generous and gracious and I asked Elaine
questions and he gave lame answers and
was fine and then Denise Richards comes
along and she says she says I am so
excited to be in a James Bond movie and
I said well you know you come from a
long line of famous Bond girls
Christmas Jones is sort of a funny name
it's kind of like [ __ ] Galore it's it's
from that school of thought and she said
how many times are people gonna [ __ ]
ask me that question
did you get that on camera no it was
live but we were recording it it was
just one of these live personal
appearance things where I was
interviewing people on the red carpet
and said she was there was nothing that
nobody know oh my god that was been
awesome you know you're just standing
there
you just hold the microphone you're
going back and forth asking questions
and [ __ ] how many times they're good
people are gonna ask you that [ __ ]
question I said well excuse the [ __ ] out
of me it's your movie premiere and I
don't want to be here either I didn't in
my head I said so yeah I wish her bad
things I wish her Betty White's future
that's what I wish Javier Bardem ray
Fiennes Naomi Harris
Sam Mendes is directing this one by the
way oh really a lot of big hopes for
this one yeah there it is all right
Saima for geek news here
[Applause]
[Music]
new video hit the interwebs this week
and I got not that video no this was
something and I'm glad a couple people
who listened the show gave me the heads
up including Luke from London here's his
email mr. Smith and mr. Garmin a
longtime listener to the show I thought
you guys I thought of you guys when I
saw this it takes two of the most
[ __ ] annoying things ever bagpipes
and unicycles and then he puts print
these [ __ ] unicycles their [ __ ] bikes I
don't know what happened to him in a
unicycle that's not like John but adds
one amazing thing a quick create
something quite spectacular love the
show keep up the good work Luke and
London Luke sent us this video I knew
Kevin you would appreciate this I
brought this in prove you haven't seen
this but it is a dude in Oregon on the
street in on a unicycle wearing a kilt
and a fedora playing a bagpipe and magic
happens
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just cycle along playing the Star Wars
theme in a bagpipe when the unicycle
that's where I keep expecting to be hit
by a rock cycle playing the bagpipes
awfully fast yes yes well here's an ER
he's on a unicycle that's true new
catwoman photos this week everyone's
been wondering what the Catwoman
costumes gonna look like in the new Dark
Knight Rises and we finally found out
and I gotta say I'm pretty excited it's
very Julie Newmar and there's your Dark
Knight Rises okay I would like to take
that he's gonna take that one back it's
very sixties Batman TV shows
here's a quick photo of their shoes and
Hathaway is Catwoman she's got the whole
mask on the cat ears the whole nine
yards
why are you booing I don't know why are
you booing where's the cleavage well the
good news is you can't see it from here
but it's assless that costumers assless
their entire ass is hanging out so when
they shoot her from behind you'll get
what you want you perv looking for naked
Catwoman check that out but for those of
us who like our Batman without boobs I'm
all for this yes I am yeah I like a boob
free Batman because you can't [ __ ]
concentrate on crime fighting crime if
you're like look at those No
a couple of weeks ago we talked about
William Shatner's new album he's got a
new album coming out in October called
seeking major Tom and it's all based on
science fiction and space oriented music
except ahim Ian Rhapsody for some reason
but we played some clips and and I just
love this guy and I love his music he is
an artiste and this week they released a
video of him behind the scenes video of
him recording the song Ironman the
classic Black Sabbath Ozzy Osbourne
Ironman the best part is you don't hear
the music track you just see Shatner
working his ass off in the studio so you
got to find it on YouTube I just brought
in a brief clip for you it's worth
checking out this is Shatner about to
burst a blood vessel in his brain
singing Ironman in the studio here we go
[Applause]
oh sweet Jesus I can't wait for that out
we come out well folks that's the end of
another Hollywood babble-on is it's
gonna be the end already yeah see how
see how time flies when you're not
stoned I know yeah weird but before we
go possible put one more clip before we
go though what's that you pull that clip
the clip of what was it the acting thing
Oh a Pierce Brosnan from tapping when he
was very upset we had the whole show I
was sitting there when that first
happened in the show is like oh my god I
gotta call that back later on and I
couldn't remember how to do it and I was
frustrated the whole time my head was on
that so now I want to hear it before we
go all right well we got it we throw in
we're throwing James a curveball here so
again II gotta give him a couple seconds
no worries take your time how you guys
doing tonight
everybody good good time thank you guys
for coming out
I only got one drink tonight by the way
I talked to management I can't if I
finish the beer honestly I'll be like
taking my top off
[Applause]
up here soldier
I haven't helped peer pressure like that
oh my god I was like I better do this
they won't hang out with me anymore I
had nothing at you personally just for
the sake of comedy there's help you were
just gonna barf all we met it we've got
a coal powered projector up there that's
the problem he's got a Stoke it and put
some in there alright [ __ ] it let's move
on alright we'll move on thank God I'm
drunk it doesn't matter
[Music]
[Music]
I gotta remember that quite well hold on
I'm gonna record her my phone I want to
yell this at my wife when I get home
just in this voice in this performance
because what's gonna happen is one day
we're gonna be watching the movie this
movie and that lines gonna happen she's
gonna look at me you son of a [ __ ] and
when she looks at me I'm gonna be like
[Music]
[Applause]
you just went for a real Pacino moment
with that yes yes cute Janice yes I'm
telling you did he watch like [ __ ]
sensible woman he was like I'm gonna do
my own version of wha and essentially
I'm gonna take lines they see what I've
got here in the script what can I use
maybe yeah that works like he had an
earwig in and the director the whole
time he was doing that one line he's
like louder louder louder louder so that
he ends of this great different phases
like all right of actors making of
actors one of our favorites of course is
the legendary Liam Neeson why God
himself
not only is he a fine fine actor but he
has an enormous [ __ ] huge
how big is the [ __ ] well we asked that
question every weekend if you'd like to
contribute your own Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
sized joke you can go to nice and calm
calm and that's how we find out just how
big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big okay let's stop okay
let's have a conversation yeah real
quick we it was fun for a little while
yeah but now not so much yeah yeah what
we meant to say is we loved it yeah it
ain't going nowhere
here we go you tried here we go this guy
is so big that he has to sleep with a
life preserver in case he has a wet
dream Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big if it
ever went missing they'd have to use all
four sides of 7008 milk cartons smart
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big in order to
practice safe sex he needed to earn a
degree in mechanical engineering Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big but not even
Conrad Murray has enough propofol to
sedate it
[Applause]
I was sorry Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that it feels self-conscious about it
and insists that it's big-boned which is
technically true Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big the Kraken releases it Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that in a lost
episode of happy days it ain't Richie's
brother Chuck now we know what happens
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big before sex
he's legally required to offer women an
epidural the women are like Liam Neeson
is so big he doesn't get would he gets
Forrest Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it's automatic it's systemic it's live
romantic lighting Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big he doesn't wear a condom he wears
a condominium
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that the
classic Abbott and Costello sketch
originally started who's on first Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] what's on second Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that it doesn't always drink beer
but when it does it prefers Dos Equis
[Applause]
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
maybe you shouldn't thank you so much
for coming out I'm Ralph Garman [ __ ] off
get out everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
gentlemen over time because it's the
world garment Hollywood babble-on why
does the Jon Lovitz podcast here
you